well hello there watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editors of the guardian and the Sun
papakura and Harry Cole with us from now
until just before midnight and welcome
to both of you so let's take a look
shall we at the front pages yes we can I
spelled the French way of course is how
the Metro reports the new deal signed
between the UK and France to try to stem
the massive increase in illegal migrants
crossing the channel
The Daily Mail meanwhile says that the
migrant crisis is hitting nurses who are
being forced out of hotel rooms to make
way for Asylum Seekers stuck your head
to Thursday's Autumn statement the eye
leads with a call from the labor
leadership for the chancellor to raise
taxes on big Tech and non-domicile tax
Exiles instead of punishing people on
low pay people's paper the guardian then
hears from two leading conservative
local councils warning Mr sunac that
they could be forced into bankruptcy if
their finances are put under any more
pressure on Thursday
what measure we can expect according to
the telegraph is Big increases in
council tax pushing average bills to
more than two thousand pounds a year but
the express says Mr sunac will at least
give pensioners the rise they're
entitled to under the pensions triple
lock
well the mirror carries a warning from
one leading pensions campaigner that if
he doesn't then pensioners will die
while the times says the chancellor will
also give a boost to the living wage to
help the low paid and pensioners
the financial times pictures the U.S and
Chinese presidents meeting at the G20
Summit but says tensions over China's
attitude to Taiwan overshadowed any
attempt to improve relations Harry's
paper the psalm has the latest Fallout
from footballer Cristiano Ronaldo's
bombshell TV interview about his
grievances with Manchester United while
the star bemoans an apparent shortage of
breakfast egg supplies being suffered by
Pub chain JD Weatherspoon
well reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
that said straight to Our Guest then
shall we pipakura and Harry Cole
um and both of you many of the
newspapers looking ahead obviously to
later this week so Pippa let's kick off
shall we with the Daily Telegraph
um suggesting that households face a
steep increase in council tax
yeah this is a story which the times
reported today
um that the chancellor Jeremy Hunt in
his Budget on Thursday his Autumn
statement is likely to scrap the cap on
council tax Rises without a local
referendum currently the situation is
that councils are allowed to put up
their
um to put up council tax to pay for
social care uh beyond the 2.99
which includes the one percent care
level but only if they have a referendum
and suggestion in the telegraph is that
it could go as high as five percent
which would potentially add a hundred
pounds or more
um onto the average Bandy properties
annual bill
um and of course for more expensive
properties it would go up even higher uh
there's been a lot of discussion about
this in government as part of the
broader measures under consideration for
putting up taxes we've heard obviously
in recent days Lots about
inheritance tax about capital or games
tax and what seems to be sort of the
main driver the main aspect here is is
freezing the threshold
um at which uh at which taxes go up so
that more people are brought in so
called fiscal track more people are
brought into paying a higher tax Band as
a result of inflation so tax is likely
to go up as Jeremy Hunt I know she's an
act of warned across the board
um but the focus on councils in
particular is really Stark because of
course so much of their budgets are do
go on uh social care whether it's for
adults or children I think talk to your
councils the average is about 70 of
their budget and because their overall
budgets have been cut so much in the
last decade by up to 60 across local
government it's one of the areas that
has been most hit by austerity and the
U.S following battered by the pandemic
as well and now obviously by by rampant
inflation and they're really struggling
to make ends meet and they have
um as well as obviously social care
costs one of the ways that they are
trying to make endometers by cutting
back on Services which are legally
obliged to provide things like school
buses Street relating refuse libraries
and so on which are sort of the
day-to-day services that people expect
from their councils so not only are they
like to see in many areas at an increase
in council tax
es
oh lost the last bit of that but anyway
we've got we got the gist of the rest of
it just quickly on this Harry because
we've got so much to pack in of
suggestions that might be in the Autumn
statement
um certainly the telegraph suggesting
that the conservative party Manifesto in
2019 pledged to keep the veto on large
council tax Rises but if we look at the
guardian
um both papers suggesting why they need
that flexibility to put money up
um the Guardians suggesting they're
going broke
oh
yeah I think there's gonna be you're
gonna start hearing a lot of warnings
from town halls just seeing the start of
them two Tory councils there saying
they're going to um you know they need
more money
um I think I understand there's been
quite a stark warning coming from the
local government Association tomorrow
perhaps the next day you know laying out
in exactly what terms they really do
need to see council tax go up to meet
their shortfalls now add into that uh
you know these referendums of thresholds
going up to make it harder to block
council tax Rises plus now we know that
you know the average household is
probably gonna be paying around 900
pounds more next spring for their energy
bills
uh based on the price cap being uh sort
of you know the price kept going up and
the support being phased out to
targeting the neediest plus all these
thresholds for income tax
um being frozen plus vat thresholds big
version and you begin to see how Jeremy
Hunt was able to say actually on Sunday
everyone will be paying more tax it
seems to me the vast majority of people
uh consumers workers will be paying more
but pensioners will be protected those
benefits to be protected and we learned
tomorrow that the minimum wage will go
up so
um you can see what they're trying to do
uh I wonder how how far they'll be able
to take Tory MPS along with it yes
they're protecting the most vulnerable
in society that is a good thing but
they're also clobbering middle class
earners homeowners and um and energy
bill payers so you wonder how
politically astute it is that it feels
like Tory voters are going to be the
ones whacked the most yeah interesting
I'm going to stay with you because this
is a story you wrote and paper I know
we're going to come to your story a bit
later on as well um you know it wasn't
long since we talked about uh defense
having three percent of GDP uh now
you've written that they're fighting
three billion pounds of cuts so tell us
about that one
yeah so what they've done quite
eloquently in in why all terms is Kick
the Can down the road as they say the
they're going to have the big row about
future defense spending
um next year uh when they set the
budgets for the years coming now what
they've done is Jeremy Hunt's made a big
thing that any any all pretty much all
departments except perhaps the NHS will
be ring fence to allow them to to to
protect them from these Cuts defense is
obviously it's incredibly politically
toxic one to be looking at cutting so it
sounds like they've struck a late deal
now to bend the rules so Ben Wallace the
defense secretary is saying there's
three there's three billion pounds a
hole in his budget because of inflation
at a time of massively heightened
National Security so the treasury have
come out this way that he'll be able to
essentially dip into ring fence money
for other defense projects that doesn't
it don't need to be paid for yet longer
term projects where the money's been
earmarked for something but he'll be
able to borrow that money bring it
forward to cover his day-to-day course
to avoid having to do any Cuts now but
eventually there will need to be An
Almighty Rao An Almighty another big
settlement to uh to meet the part the
promises that the defense secretary the
Prime Minister previous prime ministers
have made to our NATO allies and Pippa
um for once the Daily Express and the
Daily Mirror singing from the same hymn
sheet uh the protection of pensioners
this idea of the triple lock
um you know many people point to the
Richer pensioner with these non-means
tested uh help in in many areas plus the
triple lock so what are they both saying
you know look look out for older people
delima are going through us saying
they'll die
yeah well both of them obviously have um
an older readership and therefore it's
no surprise really that they're focusing
on pensions this comes obviously as
Richardson had given his strongest hint
yet that the government's going to
protect the triple lock on pensions
today he's dead the pensioners will
always be at the Forefront of his mind
the Japan triple lock which as you'll as
you'll remember is in the 2019 Manifesto
promised to put up pensions to the
highest out of inflation average
earnings or 2.5 percent obviously
inflation is soaring at the moment so
they're likely to go up dramatically and
it's prompted a lot of discussion about
where the burden's going to fall because
obviously it is working people currently
who likely is Harry as Harry so
eloquently describes likely to put to
Bear the burden of the tax Rises and to
pay for the pension Rises of the elderly
and while it is true there's lots of
pension of poverty it's also true that
working households and families
children's properties proportionately
much higher so this is really going to
be difficult for sort of the
generational divide
um uh however I think it's it's fair to
say that
um all political parties conservatives
in particular rely on the order vote um
over 60s are more likely to vote
conservative and all those old 60s are
more likely to come out and vote at an
election so obviously the government
will be wanting to keep that section of
the electorate happy even if as Harry
suggests it's difficult to get through
get past MPS who may be concerned about
homeowners and working people being hit
hit harder as a result but um obviously
this is something which the government
feels very strongly about I think we're
fully expecting the triple lock to be
maintained
um so I suspect that the Express and the
mirror on that in that regard at least
will be happy come Thursday okay Lots
must still come in the next part of our
program including in fact your story
paper 2 on the front of the Guardian
Dominic Robb was warned about his
behavior on several occasions and a
letter tonight from civil servants to
the Prime Minister back with that in
just a moment
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me now once again
peppercura and Harry Cole um Pippa let's
go to your story then which is on the
front page of the Guardian
um Dominic Robb was warned about his
behavior a story that's been rumbling
for a couple of days but what's the
latest that you found out
so the latest is this is the third
Department which we've heard about
seriously stories about after the
ministry of justice and the brexit
department
um no dissolved brexit Department this
is now when he was foreign secretary
between I think it was 2018 and 2020 he
was there and we've been told that the
then permanent secretary Simon McDonald
um was told by senior staff in in
Dominic Rob's private office about his
behavior uh which they regarded as
unacceptable and even bullying
um however they didn't want to put any
uh complaints in a formal complaints
about him because partly they feared for
their careers and secondly they felt
that it was a real privilege to work in
the department and you know a department
like the foreign office which is often
hit by crisis they obviously felt that
they were pretty tough and up to the job
and that they could continue
um but neverthelessly regardless as
brilliant to the extent that I'm told
Simon McDonald Had speak to Dominic Rob
on several occasions about his behavior
and his uh the way he addressed staff
and ran meetings and so on and it got to
the point points where nothing changed
so
um I believe that that informal
complaints so conversations were had
with the heads at a cabin officer
propriety and ethics team which is
currently sort of the formal route
through the ministerial standards
process it was flagged with them and I'm
told that Dominic's Rob's name was on a
list although of course the defense that
we've seen throughout all of this has
been that no formal complaints have been
made by civil servants and
um that has been kind of I think how the
government each department and of course
number 10 and of course the Prime
Minister has responded to this and it
just feels to me that um Rishi sinak has
constantly repeatedly talked about
integrity
um professionalism and accountability at
the top of every level of his government
and that sets a very high bar it also
really a sort of Hostage to Fortune
because if anyone is deemed too full
below that bar then potentially they
could be in trouble so you know I don't
know where there's anybody's going to
put in a formal complaint or rather
anyone has put in a formal complaint
about Dominic Rob's Behavior but if they
did it could be quite tricky territory
but regardless this and he's uh you know
it's pretty difficult questions ongoing
for for Rob who is of course up at pmqs
or Deputy pmqs against Angel arena in
the comments on Wednesday yes you
couldn't make up the timing could you um
quick comment on that and and in the
light of this letter from uh the union
for senior civil servants talking about
this toxic work culture you know
impacting the ability to deliver good
government and so on this letter that's
been written to the Prime Minister you
know is he safe um Harry do you think
yeah look I think I think he probably is
less you know Leicester some formal
complaint that's being covered up
emerges look Dominic Rob has been around
Investments for 10 years even before he
was then 15 years even before he's an MP
his sort of forthright work style should
we say was the topic of much uh
discussion even when he was a sort of
Chief of Staff to to an opposition front
bench here look this reputation has
followed him around Whitehall wherever
he's gone it's clear that words will
have to be had
um you wonder how much sunak knew about
that when he was reappointed whether it
was raised um you can obviously see the
the way the story's gone that you know
the home office tried to get you know
home office officials are trying to get
rid of Sue Ella that didn't work Gavin
Williams and obviously his past came up
to catch him uh quite rightly I think uh
and some of the things that he'd said
um you know whether we've seen anything
so far that once perhaps resignation
from Dominic Rob I don't think so I mean
the the the the fit of peak of throwing
a tomato across his death ask um doesn't
exist reads more like the thick of it
than uh than anything else
um that said look Dave Penman he's an
activist he's a union leader he you know
he's very good at getting his name in
the papers jumping on a bandwagon and
banging a drum as and when he wants to
and he's he's doing his job Harry and
God bless him for it